In the last lesson, you created your first person of
interest identifier algorithm, and you set up a training and
testing framework so that you could assess the accuracy of that model.
Now that you know much more about evaluation metrics,
we're going to have you deploy those evaluation metrics on
the framework that you've set up in the last lesson.
And so, by the time you get to the final project, the main thing that
you'll have to think about will be the features that you want to use,
the algorithm that you want to use, and any parameter tunes.
You'll already have the training and
testing, and the evaluation matrix all set up.